all right the gloves ready
question is who's going to snap their
freaking fingers
I'll do it
excuse me it's okay
don't worry just wait we haven't decided
who's gonna put that on you
oh I'm sorry we're all just sitting
around waiting for the right opportunity
we should at least discuss it look look
sitting here staring at the thing is not
going to bring everybody back
I'm the strongest Avenger okay so this
responsibility falls upon me my duty no
it's not that it's nice stop it at me
let me do it let me do something good
something right look it's not just the
fact that that glove is channeling
enough energy to light up a continent
I'm telling you you're in no condition
what do you what do you think is
coursing through my veins right now
cheers whiz
lightning yeah
blood and won't help you pal it's got to
be me
you sought those stones to the Thanos
they almost killed them
none of you could survive how do we know
you will
we don't but the radiation is mostly
gamma
it's like
I was made for this
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
let's do it
okay remember everyone Thanos snapped
away five years ago just bringing them
back to now today
I don't change anything from the last
five years
good
Friday do me a favor and activate Barn
Door protocol Wii yes boss
everybody comes home
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
take it off take it off no wait Bruce
are you okay talk to me Banner oh
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's okay